les guerres les génocides les tueries de
masse sont parmi les pires exemples de
la capacité de l'humain à faire preuve
de cruauté envers ses semblables avec le
recul on se demande parfois si ce germe
existe en chacun de nous et s'ils
pourraient se manifester sous certaines
conditions une question qu'on n'aime pas
se poser mais sur laquelle des experts
se sont penchés avec des méthodes de
parfois très controversées
dans le monde des décrypteurs que tu
connais très bien comme on le sait alors
on sait que la science a des réponses
sur pas mal de choses pas surtout bien
évidemment mais sur notre capacité en
tant qu'humain à être cruel envers
d'autres
êtres humains qu'est-ce qu'on sait
là-dessus mais c'est une expérience qui
s'est posée par beaucoup de gens
notamment après le low cost les gens se
sont demandés est-ce que n'importe qui
aurait pu être comme ces soldats nazis
qui n'avaient aucune empathie pour les
victimes et il y a une étude en
psychologie très célèbre qui a été faite
en 1960 par Stanley melgram ça peut être
un nom qui sera familier à certains à
certaines personnes parce que cette
expérience elle a été cité après ça dans
l'histoire et pour résumer un peu ce qui
s'est passé le chercheur a recruté des
volontaires en leur disant qu'ils
allaient participer à une expérience sur
la mémoire et qui avait une personne un
autre participant qui devait mémoriser
des mots et les citer les réciter et on
disait au volontaire si le participant
se trompe en disant les mots vous devez
lui donner un choc électrique donc la
personne était dans une autre salle
l'autre participant avait des électrodes
et il y avait un chercheur qui lui
disait allez-y c'est tromper vous lui
donnez un choc électrique voilà et non
seulement ça mais l'intensité des chocs
électriques augmentaient selon ce que
disait le chercheur au volontaire donc
lui disait allez-y augmenter faut lui
donner un choc plus fort parce que
exactement c'était ça le but de
l'expérience de punir quelqu'un qui se
trompait mais le problème c'est que la
personne qui recevait les chocs
électriques mais plus ça a augmenté plus
elle criait elle suppliait le volontaire
d'arrêter de lui donner des chocs
hurlait de douleur et même un certain
moment la personne a perdu connaissance
mais bon ce que les participants ne
savaient pas les volontaires qui
donnaient les chocs c'est que c'était un
acteur donc il y a pas de vrais chocs
qui se donnaient alors la vraie
expérience c'était le château de voir
est-ce que le volontaire allait obéir
aveuglément aux ordres du chercheur qui
lui disait allez-y donner un choc
électrique à l'autre personne même si
elle a mal même si elle se plainte et ce
qui ressorti l'expérience de milgrams
que la culture populaire a retenue c'est
que les volontaires obéissaient
aveuglement aux chercheurs en Sarah
parce qu'il lui disait de faire ça il
laissait de côté leur empathie le septé
leur conscience c'est une expérience
après ça qui a été cité pour justifier
des massacres ou des des tortures durant
différents conflits dans le monde
notamment en Irak lorsqu'il y a eu ces
soldats qui ont torturé des prisonniers
à bougrahim voilà donc on le dit ben
c'est un exemple que sous l'autorité
d'une personne on est capable de
commettre n'importe quelle atrocité donc
très clairement Bouchra c'est une étude
qui a servi à justifier à légitimer des
atrocités mais généralement ce qu'on en
a retenu ne correspond pas à ce qui
s'est produit dans la réalité là oui
mais dans la réalité il y a eu beaucoup
plus de nuances richesse qui a été
rapporté dans les médias et en 2013 il y
a une chercheuse du nom de Gina Perry
qui retournait dans les données de
l'étude qui a analysé vraiment plus en
détail ce qui s'est passé et on se rend
compte que beaucoup de nuances donc
premièrement il y a beaucoup de
volontaires qui ont protesté qui
refusaient d'aller plus loin dans les
chocs électriques même si le chercheur
leur disait et lorsqu'il s'opposaient le
chercheur insistait vraiment il leur
imposé de continuer il disait vous devez
le faire pour la science donc il
n'obéissait pas aveuglément il y avait
vraiment le scénario complètement voilà
donc il y avait des frictions entre les
participants et les chercheurs et donc
il y en a qui désobéissaient il y en a
qui finissaient par accepter mais
vraiment à contrecoeur dans certains cas
aussi le volontaire qui recevait les
chocs ne manifestaient pas toujours de
la même façon sa souffrance donc
certaines personnes ne le voyaient pas
souffrir autant que d'autres et il y a
certains participants aussi qui avaient
décidé que c'était une mise en scène et
donc qui
vous donner ces chocs en sachant très
bien que la personne ne les recevais pas
vraiment donc finalement ce qui en
ressort c'est que les gens n'ont pas
obéi aussi aveuglément qu'on leur
apporte beaucoup de gens refusaient de
faire souffrir ce pauvre participant ce
qui fait en sorte que c'est hautement
controversé comme expérience et mais
dis-moi en dehors de cette expérience
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres qui ont été
faites sur ce sujet là sur cette cette
question qu'on peut se poser mais
effectivement c'est une question qui
fascine en psychologie le savoir est-ce
qu'on a tous un monstre qui se met en
nous et une dizaine d'années après
l'expérience de melground il y a un
autre célèbre psychologue américain
Philippe Zimbardo à l'université
Stanford lui fait ce qu'on appelle
l'expérience de prison de Stanford donc
créer une prison fictive mais il a
recruté des participants pour jouer le
rôle des prisonniers et jouer le rôle
des gardiens et tous les participants
c'était des jeunes adultes des étudiants
universitaires donc tous des personnes
qui venaient du même milieu mais il les
a séparé aléatoirement en le groupe un
groupe de 9 personnes allaient être les
prisonniers et un autre groupe de 9
personnes allaient être les gardiens et
c'est une expérience qui devait durer
deux semaines et elle a été arrêtée au
bout de six jours et encore une fois ce
qu'on en a retenu c'est que les gardiens
sont rapidement tellement rentrés dans
leur rôle qu'ils ont commencé à être
cruel envers les prisonniers et que ça
ça dégénérait mais là encore quand on se
penche sur les détails on voit qu'il y a
des nuances donc une des choses qui a
mené supposément à l'arrêt prématuré de
cette expérience c'est que un des
prisonniers d'un gosse corpie serait
devenu vraiment hystérique il aurait
crié supplié de sortir parce qu'il était
trop maltraité mais cet homme là plus
tard a expliqué qu'en fait il jouait la
comédie et qu'il voulait sortir non pas
parce qu'il était maltraité par les
gardes mais parce que il voulait revenir
à sa vie habituelle il y avait des
examens à passer il voulait étudier il
s'est rendu compte que moyens de sortir
de cette prison avant que les deux
semaines soient écoulées à moins de
vraiment prétendre qu'il était en crise
et on a constaté aussi donc finalement
que les gardiens ne sont pas comme on le
rapporte deux même devenu des bureaux
simplement parce qu'on leur a donné ce
rôle là en fait les chercheurs les
scientifiques avaient vraiment expliqué
au gardien qui devait être plus méchant
qui devait créer de la peur auprès des
prisonniers donc on leur explique que
c'était pour les bienfaits de
l'expérience qui devait jouer ce rôle de
gardien très dur c'était encore une fois
assis nuancée et on en retient que ce
n'est pas parce qu'on vous met dans un
rôle d'autorité que vous perdez toute
votre votre conscience et votre
empathique vous devenez un tyran mais
qu'est-ce qu'on sait au final sur cette
capacité cette aptitude potentielle en
nous de devenir méchant cruel envers nos
semblables mais je pense peut être quand
même rassurer à la lumière de ces
études-là que finalement on n'a pas tous
un tortionnaire qui se met en nous cela
dit on observe quand même dans
l'histoire que il y a de l'influence
d'autrui il y a des gens qui parient
fait d'entraînement par effet de groupe
fait que certaines personnes peuvent
être amenées à poser des gestes qui
n'auraient pas posé demain mais ce n'est
pas on n'a pas une confiance aveugle
dans l'autorité et on peut se rassurer
de savoir que la plupart d'entre nous si
on est une personne avec un bon cœur ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui risque de
disparaître du jour au lendemain parce
qu'on y place dans certaines
circonstances en tout cas ça c'est ton
cas c'est de source sûre très bon coeur
et tu as de l'empathie c'est pour ça
qu'on t'aime on aime te recevoir à
l'émission on se dit une prochaine à la
prochaine salut